На тісну співпрацю Парижа та Берліна, а саме
канцлерки Анґели Меркель та Еммануеля Макрона
парижанка Шанталь Лейб сподівалася найбільше.
Прихильницю руху Макрона "Вперед", втім, гірко
засмутили результати коаліційних переговорів у Берліні.
Тому що це віддаляє плани її президента
щодо побудови сильної Європи.
Якщо не просувати ідеї Європи,
Німеччина буде рухатися в бік Росії та Китаю,
а Франція повернеться до Середземного моря
і тоді Європі буде край.
Європа з єдиною армією та єдиним обраним президентом -
Шанталь Лейб поділяє таке майбутнє бачення
свого президента.
Має на це особисті причини, пояснює вона.
Її батько - французький єврей, а мати – німецька християнка.
Сімейна історія зробила Шанталь Лейб
переконаною європейкою.
Європу я виношую у собі з колиски.
Ми завжди відзначали різні європейські свята
і вивчали різні європейські культури.
Спільна Європа, із локомотивами Німеччиною і
Францією, для Шанталь є ідеальним баченням.
Але у Франції його поділяють не всі.
Наприклад, Жюльен Абер вважає добрим знаком
затримку з формуванням коаліції в Німеччині.
Тому що німці, на його думку, в останні десять років
стали надто сильними.
Раніше ми мали ірраціональну ненависть до німців.
Зараз ми маємо ірраціональну любов до Німеччини.
Але насправді ми нічого не виграємо,
якщо віддамо ключі від вантажівки Німеччині,
а самі застрягнемо десь позаду.
Франція так і зробила.
Шанталь Лейб, навпаки, вважає важливим,
аби Німеччина швидко вирішила урядову кризу.
Можливо, каже вона, настав час німцям заснувати
абсолютно новий політичний рух,
такий як французький  "Вперед".
Тоді б і у Німеччині, можливо, з'явилась успішна
альтернатива традиційним партіям.
Німцям слід узяти частину від ХДС, частину
від СДПН і частину  від вільних демократів
і заснувати новий рух.
Я думаю, з традиційними партіями
це буде неможливо зробити.
Спочатку Brexit, тепер урядова криза в Німеччині.
На думку французьких експертів, Еммануелю
Макрону буде не так легко провести свої євро-реформи.
Тут нічого нового для європейців немає.
Але така ситуація політичної невизначеності
в Німеччині ускладнить реформування
єврозони та ЄС.
Це може позначитись і на просуванні
євроінтеграційних планів України.
Адже через політичну невизначеність у Європі
питання України може відійти на другий план.
Цікаво, чи привнесе рефоматор Макрон - як нове
обличчя на саміті Cхідного партнерства - нові
акценти щодо східних партнерів?